hey Kenny I have a very special guest
this is Butch Stockton this is Mitchell
Robinson's high school basketball coach
who is currently living with Mitchell
here in New York but you must be a good
luck charm because Mitchell's having an
awesome season what have you seen from
him so far this year you know first of
all Rebecca Mitch been really focused on
rebounding and I think he's a leading
offensive Rebound in the NBA right at
this time and he's he not talk about
rebounding and he's so determined to be
the leading rebounder
in NBA that's his one of his main goals
and he's doing a wonderful job with that
now let's get back to the fact that you
two are roommates this season how did
that come together you know first of all
my wife passed away in September and uh
Mitchell when my wife's in the hospital
Mitchell came each day to visit her and
came very close to myself and my wife
and after the funeral M told everyone
that he was going to bring me to New
York with him he said coach there's no
reason you stay down here in Louisiana
anymore you come to New York with me and
enjoy yourself and get your mind back
straight because you know how much you
loved your wife how much I like loved
your wife and it's just been a great
situation Rebecca ban wonderful bond
between you two how would you describe
Mitch off the floor you know Mitch is a
very caring person he cares about
everyone and I'm just speaking not on my
behalf but anyone that's close to
Mitchell he cares about him and other
thing about Mitchell Robinson is he's
very sincere about it he really is and I
can't than Mitchell enough and I'll be
honest I have really enjoyed it up here
especially at Mitchell power like
another roommate I guess you know kind
of being funny about it well love it
you're welcome to stay in New York as
long as possible all season preferably
because Mitchell's been amazing thank
you so much but thank you so much for
back and I really want to thank everyone
for having me and especially New York
Nicks family has been very thankful for
me and I can't thank Nick's family
enough thank you so much Kenny back to
you